until and just to follow up from what
you've gathered so far based on those
noises should that be it for families
and
the others who care for these people
so a couple things one I think when
you're in the middle of a search and
rescue case you always have hope that's
that's why we're doing what we do
um with respect to the noises
specifically
we don't know what they are to be frank
with you um we the the P3 detected
noises that's why they're up there
that's why they're doing what they're
doing that's why they put sonar buoys in
the water
um
the good news is what I can tell you is
we're searching in the area where the
noises were detected and we'll continue
to do so and we we hope
um that when we're able to get
additional rovs which will be there in
the morning the intent will be to
continue to search in those areas where
the noise were detected and if they're
continuing to be detected and then put
additional rovs down in a last known
position where the search was originally
taking place
intervals as reported I hadn't heard a
30-minute intervals so here's what I can
tell you we so
I I am not a trained here for underwater
Aquatics that's why we have a team of
experts that are analyzing that data
that data was sent immediately to uh to
the Navy uh last night and it was
analyzed overnight they're still looking
at it but I can tell you that it's it's
inconclusive but again I think the
important piece is we're searching in
the area where the noise were detected
can you talk about a timeline can you
talk about what timeline you're working
on in conjunction with the teams that
are there it's a timeline of what
respect how much oxygen they have left
off okay all right so
well
in terms of so we talked about the
auction number I think you're all
tracking the oxygen number I think
there's an important point with that
though the oxygen that that that's just
one piece of data right there there are
a lot of pieces of data that we need to
consider and
you know we're continuously looking at
that and we'll continuously uh you know
do that throughout the search
um
but that's not the only thing that's
important right and right now our
efforts are are solely focused on the
search that certainly is a dialogue
that's happening
um but uh but we're focused on searching
at this point a recovery
oh this is a this is a search and rescue
mission 100 we are smack dab in the
middle of search and rescue and uh and
uh we'll continue to put every available
asset that we have in an effort to to
find the Titan and the crew members
confirm that some sort of rectangular
object has been spotted there was some
sort of report about that I don't know
so a couple things so the rovs all each
ROV brings different capability uh the
rovs that are diving today
um but what's the what's the depth on
the 2000 yeah 4 000 meters
um and they some additional rovs that'll
be arriving tomorrow have additional
depth capability
um with respect to uh an object so
yesterday one of the aircraft uh did see
an object I will tell you this in search
and rescue missions when aircraft are
flying continuously there is stuff out
in the ocean that is floating
um we went back we looked at it it it
wasn't we didn't determine it to be
debris we don't think it's it correlates
with the case and it is not uncommon at
all during an active search to see
things and then we go and look at them
so
just